so if you start and say I'm going to
create one YouTube video a week that's
giving you five ten short burn pieces of
content just as a first starting point a
15 to 30 second clip and post it
everywhere how do you encourage people
that are just getting started when
they're trying to learn these new skill
sets hey welcome back to the think media
podcast I'm super fired up for this
episode because we're going to be
talking about how do you eliminate
overwhelm and repurpose content
intelligently so ultimately you can get
more subscribers of course this applies
across social media platforms and our
guest today is Latasha James after
spending a few years in Fortune 500
companies non-profits and Tech startups
she launched her company James and park
she's been scaling a marketing business
is still in the freelance industry with
digital marketing strategy and then also
as a content creator she's helping
people become social media managers
Freelancers and sharing Rockstar tips
for how you can create better content
and ultimately get your message business
out to more people so Latasha thanks for
coming on the podcast thank you so much
for having me so I'm excited to dive in
we're here in San Diego social media
marketing world and uh you just spoke on
repurposing content yes and it's a big
buzzword right now because there's all
this demand to like I need to be
everywhere be posting everywhere and
people feel very overwhelmed what's kind
of the state of maybe people creating
content right now when you think about
so much to do in so many so little time
yeah well I think that overwhelm word is
a key theme for all my clients my
students they're like I just don't know
where to focus I can't be everywhere all
at once and so repurposing really is my
answer I am actually the sole producer
of all my content still which is a
little bit wild but you know it really
starts long form for me and I think that
there is so much power in short form
content absolutely like we can't ignore
that but I always say that repurposing
down is so much easier than repurposing
up and you know stitching together 15
second Clips to make a YouTube video so
focus on that core pillar piece of
content to start whether that is a
podcast a YouTube channel for me it's a
video podcast so combining those two and
then repurposing down and that way you
can just distribute across the smaller
social channels without all of that
overwhelm without having to think about
like okay what am I going to talk about
on Tick Tock now what am I going to talk
about on Instagram reels you already
have that that system down so you've
been on YouTube 10 years yes podcasting
five years yes and how much content are
you kind of putting out a week by
yourself yeah two videos a week on
YouTube so one is the video podcast so
the moving the podcast to video was a
piece of this you know that this
repurposing was a big piece of that
thought process because I was recording
a separate audio podcast and I was like
hold on why don't I just put my camera
you know set my camera up and make this
a part of the YouTube channel as well so
kind of killing two birds with one stone
there so I started doing that probably
two years into the podcast so I've been
video podcasting for three years but
yeah two two YouTube videos a week and
so then once you've produced those how
much micro content repurpose content do
you typically pull out of those episodes
yeah minimum I'm thinking back to my
slides yesterday I'm like minimum on
Fridays there's about eight pieces of
content that comes out of that one big
piece of content to start so there's you
know YouTube the podcast I pull a
transcript that I can use in my
newsletter in an Ideal World I'd be
doing a Blog too but that's next level
I'm not there yet and then a few pieces
of short form content so Tick Tock
Instagram reels LinkedIn Twitter
Facebook wherever yeah um so yeah
there's you know up to like eight pieces
of content and do you edit all that
yourself and then edit from the long
form into the short form Clips what
software do you yeah so I use Final Cut
for my main video editor and I find it
really easy if you are editing your own
content just to do it like make it a
part of your long form editing process
so I just use the marker feature and
whenever I hear something that kind of
makes my ear perk up I just drop a
marker there on that first pass through
and then that way when I'm going through
to do all of the additional you know you
know finalized final edits I can just
clip those into vertical or whatever I
need um there's also a really cool tool
I'm sure you've heard of it called
descript yep so I use that one a lot for
backlogged Content so you know I have I
mean 500 or so videos on my YouTube
channel so I look at some of those top
performers throw those into dscript and
then I can basically do the same thing
there what's really cool is that they
have that search feature so I can search
for different keywords like I'll search
for numbers because people love numbers
in short form content for yes exactly or
any type of percentage or statistic or
anything like that so that's really cool
and so then you what is kind of I saw
you had a three-step process that
someone kind of shared from uh your
session and they were saying that that
step one is create an outline for your
long form video what's the important of
pre-planning when doing this repurposing
stuff yeah for sure I mean when I first
started on YouTube
um and before I was really thinking
short form first I was just kind of
turning on the camera and and talking
and I think there's some value in that
for sure brings that humility that that
authenticity but uh when you're thinking
about eight different platforms you got
to be a little bit more strategic so I
don't script my videos but I do outline
everything I just do bullet point
outlines and making sure you know when I
look at that outline again if I see like
an interesting way that I can tie in a
three tips for this or an interesting
statistic like I just did a podcast
about
um why you should be a social media
manager why that's a great you know
freelance gig to start so I'm like you
know what let me make sure that I pull
some some statistics I went on to
LinkedIn and found some interesting data
that I knew was going to stand well on
its own in that short form version
um that short format so I can just make
sure sure that I'm planning ahead as
opposed to like going the reverse and
having to search through the content and
find something that's actually going to
be compelling are you ready to start or
grow your YouTube channel do you feel
stuck and need help connecting the dots
join this free web class where you'll
learn the step-by-step playbook for
YouTube success we've helped thousands
of purpose-driven entrepreneurs just
like you grow their influence with video
register today for this exclusive
training at thinkmasterclass.com got it
so react prior planning prevents poor
performance like for sure or you go into
it thinking all the way until the end
result of this is eventually going to be
micro and then secondly you say frame
your shot horizontal and vertical what's
your thinking there yeah so again old
I'm like an old school YouTuber so I
feel like it was the trend to be very
zoomed in and again I see the value in
that because it makes you feel very
close to the person right nowadays we
gotta think of multiple formats so I
just zoomed my camera out just a little
bit you know we want it to still of
course work well on the YouTube format
but that makes it so much easier to crop
it so that your your face is not like
completely zoomed in on the phone uh and
Tick Tock actually has a in their
advertising tools they have a like a PNG
that you can download and overlay over
your shot just to kind of test it and it
shows you that safe area so you're
supposed to be in this little green
rectangle so you can make sure that your
focal point which in most cases is going
to be a face if you're filming an object
a product or maybe that product make
sure that that's within that safe area
so that all the tick tock controls
aren't covering it up and I kind of use
that as a loose guideline for Instagram
reels too it's a similar format that's
super strong and then number three
schedule time of the week to repurpose
your content every week you said you do
that on Friday do you sit down at that
point and Export the stuff or is that
also where you're manually then
uploading your tick tocks and reels yeah
I act so I actually do my repurposing on
Tuesdays I do it as part of my group I
have a membership group and we co-work
we actually do a video co-working
session so we just all get together on
Zoom turn our microphones on mute and
like co-work for an hour and it's really
helpful because it holds me accountable
to actually do it I think repurposing is
one of those things that's so easy to
put off you're like okay did that big
piece of content you know and that feels
like the big like I did it I'll get to
repurposing when I get to it and if you
do that you're just not going to be held
accountable so yeah I use that time to
just go through and clip those any
markers that I've left in Final Cut add
any captions that I want to add
um you know just just get it I also
schedule it out onto the platforms too I
love it and so talk to me about the why
so sometimes after hearing all this even
this could create some overwhelm though
you wanted to film School you've been
doing this a lot of years it's like a
muscle you're like a bodybuilder in
terms of repurposing content you know
but when someone's just starting it's
like man just learning editing and
learning all these different tools yeah
so there's kind of two sides to the
question one would secondly would be how
do you kind of pace yourself and grow
into this but first why even do all this
are you finding result adults and when
you repurpose content is it leading to
leads is it opening up more opportunity
because of course if it's not getting
results then why go to all this effort
for sure great question I think you have
to test in you know marketing is one big
test so definitely I'm not going to tell
you to you know create completely shift
your YouTube strategy to go all in on
Tick Tock if it if it doesn't do
anything and and so I'm big on data
looking at my analytics and seeing where
those leads are coming from for me it
still is primarily YouTube that is my
number one refer to anything that I sell
is YouTube it's really powerful so with
that said you know the repurposing it
isn't Reinventing the wheel it's super
easy to do like I focus YouTube first my
strategy is always YouTube first what's
going to be best for YouTube and then if
it it's an easy cut if it's an Easy Clip
like let's just let's just do it what I
do find from short form is that it
really helps with brand so it really
helps with getting people excited about
content and and I actually have found
that it does lead people back to the
podcast as well there are Little Things
One of the tips that I shared yesterday
was just renaming your audio that's such
a quick fix in on Tick Tock or Instagram
reels so that all of my audio always
says freelance Friday podcast or Latasha
james.com podcast or something similar
yeah so that you know when people are
seeing those little sound bites and they
are going viral they're not for nothing
people are seeing okay this person's a
podcaster let me go check that out and I
do hear anecdotally that people do that
a lot that's a great tip and to break
that down that's where usually it's a
song If you use a song but when it's
original audio it might just say
original audio and you can actually
rename it and then get a little brand
pump to actually put your brand name in
there or whatever and someone's like
what you know as it's scrolling by and
all those little touch points are what
make up a brand yeah as people see you
more they get to you want your brand to
be sticky and takes time to do that for
sure so then secondly is speak to your
journey because I think I want people to
really hear you've been on YouTube 10
years you went to film school and so
this really isn't overnight you in terms
of these skill sets you're sitting down
you're doing markers you're reverse
engineering the whole thing and doing an
outline how do you encourage people that
are just getting started when they're
trying to learn these new skill sets
just start honestly just start my first
YouTube video I think you had my tweet
pulled up earlier it was filmed on a
Samsung point and shoot camera like not
a DSLR like the old school digital
cameras from you know the early 2000s
balanced on a coffee table my head was
cut off no audio like it was terrible
um I'm gonna be honest and that that's
part of the process I mean every single
year even even videos I've shot six
months ago I look at them I'm like what
was I doing and that's progress you know
that that means that you're growing so I
actually love that I cringe at some of
my old videos but I actually love that
so I definitely did not start here I
know that you did not start where you
are you know it takes time it takes
building that muscle so just start with
what you have don't don't even worry
about equipment if you have an iPhone I
mean that's better than that Samsung
Samsung point-and-shoot camera that I
was using back 10 years ago so just
start with what you have and even with
the repurposing stuff because I know it
can be a little overwhelming even this
process that I'm sharing just just start
by click cutting one clip from each
YouTube video and posting it everywhere
you can refine that strategy you can get
a little bit more strategic about what
you're posting where and timing and
staggering your content once you kind of
get in that flow but just as a first
starting point just make sure you clip a
15 to 30 second clip and post it
everywhere and and that's how I grew my
tech talk I mean my Tick Tock is my
smallest platform for sure but I
wouldn't I mean that's how I've grown it
is just by posting like podcast Clips on
there yeah that's amazing and uh in 2023
if someone was starting from scratch and
they could only invest in one place
where would you recommend they build
their personal brand and why YouTube
youtube.com
um seriously I I think that it's first
of all when we're talking about short
form content too I'm very excited to see
what YouTube does with shorts I know
it's very early early stages of it but
you know YouTube treats their creators
really well in my experience better than
some of the other platforms and so I'm
excited to see where that goes because
one of the issues I'm seeing with a lot
of my friends who are huge on Tick Tock
and shorter firm platforms is they're
just not seeing you know the the money
from it unless they have something to
sell and so very excited to see what
YouTube does with that
um but on long form I still do think
there is such value in creating
long-form content it is not dead there's
a reason that we've watched movies for
years and TV shows and we we pretty much
always will it is really the best place
for authoritative content thought
leadership content if somebody sits here
and you know produces 50 videos 50 15
minute videos about one topic that tells
me they're passionate about it that
tells me they're knowledgeable about it
that is really the go-to for
authoritative content and then again
it's so much easier to repurpose down
than do the reverse so if you start and
say I'm going to create one YouTube
video a week that's giving you five ten
short-born pieces of content a week as
well so many bombs you dropped in this
podcast you're doing a lot of cool stuff
so if people want to connect with you
where can they find you and of course
check out the show notes we'll link
everything up uh but where are you at
yeah at the Latasha James everywhere
Instagram Twitter
um all that and then YouTube I'm just
Latasha James latashjames.com for
courses and everything like that I
appreciate you so much thank you so much